bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin les
travaux de la commission des finances du
sénat sur la réforme de la fiscalité du
patrimoine il s'agit de la deuxième
table ronde consacrée à ce sujet par les
sénateurs parmi les questions posées ce
matin pourquoi faire cette réforme
quelle forme doit elle prendre quelle
sont les impôts qu'ils doivent être
inclus dans son champ et quels résultats
peut-on en apprendre je vous rappelle
qu'un projet de loi sera présenté en
conseil des ministres mi mai sur la
réforme de l'appel de la fiscalité du
patrimoine
parmi les personnes auditionnées par les
sénateurs puis à refaire nous auteurs de
la gestion fiscale du patrimoine
bernard monassier vice président du
cercle des fiscalistes gervais morel
collaborateurs de la boîte à outils du
contribuable au figaro économie
et enfin michel taly président fondateur
de l'institut de politique fiscale tout
de suite donc direction à la salle
clémenceau très bonne machine à tous
nous allons à présent poursuivre nos
travaux sur la future réforme de la
fiscalité du patrimoine avec une table
ronde réunissant des professionnels
experts de la matière fiscale et qui
peuvent être appelés à conseiller leurs
clients
dans ce domaine il s'agit d'un point de
vue que le législateur ne saurait
ignorer temps le système actuel dans sa
complexité nécessite l'intervention de
conseil pour le meilleur et quelquefois
pour le pire
nous recevons ce matin monsieur pierre
faire nous maître de conférences à la
faculté de droit de clermont ferrand et
auteur d'un ouvrage de référence
intitulé la gestion fiscale du
patrimoine
nous recevons monsieur bernard monassier
notaire et vice président du cercle des
fiscalistes monsieur gervais morel
fiscaliste experts comptables et
collaborateurs de la boîte à outils du
contribuable au figaro économie et nous
recevons monsieur michel taly avocat
président fondateur de l'institut de
politique fiscale et dont les anciennes
fonctions à la direction de la
législation fiscale lui permettent
d'aborder le problème sous plusieurs
angles
messieurs nous comptons sur vous pour
nous indiquer comment vous appréhendez
la réforme de la fiscalité patrimoniale
dont le principe a été annoncé par le
président de la république je vous
invite à effectuer l'un après l'autre
une prestation liminaire aussi concise
que possible de moins de 10 minutes si
vous le voulez bien de façon dont vous
concevez cette réforme
en répondant plus spécifiquement aux
questions suivantes pourquoi faire cette
réforme quelle forme doit elle prendre
quels impôts devrait être dans son champ
et quels résultats
peut-on en attendre je passerai ensuite
la parole au rapporteur général et bien
entendu mais
la collègue à chacun d'entre vous si
vous souhaitez intervenir et bien pour
commencer peut-être que monsieur faire
nous pourrait nous livrer son
appréciation
monsieur le président pied le micro la
fac de puissions vous entendre il était
à semble-t-il
je vous remercie monsieur le président
de bien vouloir me donner la parole je
remercie également monsieur le
rapporteur général que j'avais côtoyés
dans un colloque fille droit en 1999
époque à laquelle j'avais déjà admis un
certain nombre de propositions qui à
l'époque faisait quelque peu réfléchi
dans un sens pas forcément favorable
mais je pense que les idées que j'avais
émis à cette époque là je vais maintenir
parce que ce qu'il me paraît très
important
c'est l'article 13 de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme chacun des coupes
citoyen doit participer à l'impôt en
fonction de ses facultés contributives
et la question que me su poser c'est est
ce que c'est encore le cas et la réponse
en ce qui concerne la fiscalité du
patrimoine bien entendu la réponse est
non aussi bien pour l'impôt sur le
revenu que pour les droits
d'enregistrement ou pour l' isf en
matière d'impôt sur le revenu
je me suis inspiré et je suis revenu à
l'esprit de 1914
comme quoi des fois les anciens ont
quelques peut-être du génie parce que
lorsque cet impôt sur le revenu a été
mis en place en 1914
on avait une superposition de 2,6 de
deux régimes d'imposition des impôts
cellulaire d'une part et l'impôt
progressif sur le revenu d'autre part
c'est à dire que chaque catégorie de
revenus était soumise à un taux
spécifiques
ensuite on regroupe l ensemble dans un
revenu global qui étaient soumis au
barème ce qui n'est pas très loin d'être
le cas actuellement puisque tous les
revenus sont soumis aux cotisations
sociales quelques pas bien or ce qui m'a
intéressé beaucoup à cette époque l'un
c'est que la fiscalité était orienté en
faveur du professionnel
et on le voyait bien dans les impôts
cellulaire parce que dans les impôts
cellulaires les catégories
professionnelles subissait un taux de 6%
alors que les revenus du patrimoine
comme les revenus fonciers par exemple
qui existait déjà à l'époque était
soumis à 12%
la raison était la distinction entre les
revenus non causée par la perpétuité est
la durabilité de la source de revenus et
les revenus causées qui n'était qu' eu
un venait de la détention d'un
patrimoine pendant x années équité qui
était destiné à procurer des revenus
pendant une durée indéfinie et donc on
taxait plus lourdement les revenus du
patrimoine - lourdement les revenus des
professionnels et ça me paraît un axe de
réflexion important que un exemple est
très simple un exemple très simple un
professionnel dans la gestion de
patrimoine créé un poste de travail
il va investir à partir des bénéfices
qu'il a réalisés sur lesquels il a été
imposé
il va créer un poste d'emploi il va
créer des recettes fiscales tva revenus
de la personne qui l'emploie tout
bénéfice qu'il va réaliser et soumis au
taux marginal de l'impôt
au lieu de ça qu at-il intérêt faire
mais il a tout simplement un terrain
mais ça dans un contrat d'assurance vie
1 parce qu'il payera 2,3 pour cent au
pire des cas
donc il a aucune aucun intérêt à
investir dans l'économie il intérêt à
réaliser un placement que j'appelle des
fois dormant donc ça c'est un premier
axe dans la fiscalité des revenus le
second le second cas concerne et je
crois que monsieur ali avait parlé
également de st c'est la question de
l'application d'un taux fixe à certains
types de revenus comme les plus values
comme les dividendes le prélèvement
libératoire de 10 9%
les plus values sont taxés à 31,3 que se
passe-t-il au regard de l'équité et de
l'égalité devant l'impôt
quelqu'un qui a un taux moyen de 20% va
payer 31,3 sur une plus value
immobilière quelqu'un
un qui est un taux de 50% prélèvements
sociaux compris payera 31,3 je trouve
que c'est une curieuse façon d'aborder
la contribution aux charges publiques en
fonction des facultés contributives de
chacun
j'ai donc je considère donc
personnellement que toutes les
catégories de revenus devaient être
devrait être incluse dans le revenu
global pour être soumise au taux
marginal de l'impôt chacun perret en
fonction de ses facultés contributives
même chose pour les dividendes en un
prélèvement de 19 % sur des dividendes
très bien est-ce qu'on a intérêt à
investir si on distribuait on paye 10 9%
sur des dividendes
à l'évidence non et plus on perçoit
dividende - aussi un intérêt puisqu'on
il a été démontré un par des calculs que
les bénéficiaires de cette situation
sont des gens à hauts revenus donc c'est
le deuxième axe qui serait la
suppression de ces impositions à taux
fixe pour entrer toutes les catégories
de revenus dans le barème en 95 une
étude avait été faite qui montrait que
le taux moyen maximum compte sur lequel
on était imposé
si on inclut et tous les revenus dans le
revenu global était de 38% deuxième
deuxième chose il faudrait dans les
catégories de revenus revenir un peu de
de cohérence les régimes fiscaux sont
absolument inconnu je prends un exemple
extrêmement simple un particulier achète
à local qu'ils donnent en location
meublée
il peut déduire les frais d'acquisition
il peut amortir l'immeuble celui qui
achète un local lui ne le peut pas
pourquoi ne peut-il pas déduire un
amortissement ce qui avait été prévu par
le législateur en 1933
sachez que une réponse ministérielle de
1934 disait que le bailleur de l'eau
connu pouvait choisir entre une
déduction forfaitaire de 30 % ou un
amortissement selon un mode réel
voilà des choses qui sont pas très très
logique ont discuté avec m monassier qui
peut actuellement remplir une
déclaration de revenus fonciers
personnes
on est obligé d'aller voir un
spécialiste qui est très bien pour nous
peut-être direz vous mais je suis pas
sûr que ce soit très bien
pour le citoyen en ce qui concerne
maintenant je peux rapidement ce qui
concerne l' isf
oui mais oui donc pour l' isf
moi mon idée est plus simple c'est un
problème de confiance légitime donc un
système fiscal doit assure une confiance
légitime à ce qu'ils utilisent
le problème c'est quoi ces cons-là créer
un bouclier fiscal qui a fait qu'un
certain nombre de personnes sont revenus
ceux localisés en france la suppression
de ce bouclier fiscal créé une
incertitude qui font que nombre de
personnes sont tentées de repartir
d'autant que la suppression du bouclier
fiscal supposerait si on être logique
une suppression de l isf si on veut être
logique en matière de droits
d'enregistrement pléthore m monassier en
et plus encore compétents que moi pour
en parler
l'ombre de régimes sont
extraordinairement compliquée mis en a
un très très grand nombre
en tout cas on constate une chose c'est
que quelqu'un qui sait habilement manié
les stratégies fiscales peut transmettre
par exemple une entreprise j'ai fait
quelques calculs en douze ans il peut
transférer il peut transmettre une
entreprise de 30 millions d'euros avec
le démembrement de propriété en font 6 2
devant bon est ce normal est-ce pas
normal on peut en discuter
donc voilà ce que je voulais dire si
vous voulez en at-il le propos liminaire
si on remercie pour ces principes
évitez taxer ce qui est productif de
richesse m
de la simplicité dans le barème en
incluant l'ensemble des revenus au
barème général et si l'on doit faire
disparaître le bouclier qui avait été
peut-être à l'origine de retour de
certaines fortunes il faudrait
logiquement faire disparaître également
lié sait peut-être que m
ma d'acier pourrait intervenir
maintenant s'il veut bien oui
je commencerai par rappeler un certain
nombre de faits fiscalité d'un parc de
lits sf je crois qu'il faut parler d'un
problème plus global de la fiscalité du
patrimoine
tout le monde sait la fiscalité du
patrimoine en france par rapport à notre
pib est très supérieur à la moyenne de
l'oscd eux très supérieur à la moyenne
de l'union européenne
très supérieur à l'allemagne 2 1 à 3 en
moyenne
donc premier point il faut savoir ca du
deuxième point la fiscalité du
patrimoine
ce n'est pas que les sf comme le disait
monsieur faire nous ce sont les droits
d'enregistrement moment de l'acquisition
d'un bien ce sont les la taxation au
niveau de la détention par lit et s'est
fait par l'impôt foncier et c'est la
taxation au niveau de la sortie du
patrimoine par les plus values et par
les droits de succession les droits de
donation
on a maintenant pour la fiscalité du
patrimoine un patch fort merveilleux
pour les professionnels un conte
principe pour le contribuable et qui
fait que si on est habile on peut
échapper une partie non négligeable si
on est moins habile on n'y échappe pas
et ça rend l'impôt incompréhensible et
donc le contribuable temps à le rejeter
et c'est dangereux quoi démocratie 30
secondes sur ces trois formes d'impôts
et ensuite je viendrai à l' isf droits
d'enregistrement quand on achète un
pavillon de banlieue 5,1 que 10 % de
droits d'enregistrement
lorsque on achète des parts d'un
groupement forestier 125 euros
lorsqu'on achète par un groupement
agricole 125 euros forfaitaires je
pourrais multiplier à 75 régimes
différents formidable pour les
professionnels où est la logique
qu'est ce qu'on veut faire en veut à
facilités d'accès du citoyen à la
propriété immobilière et on a des taux
qui sont plus élevés que la moyenne
européenne
et on a des régimes dérogatoires qui
s'ajouté qui s'additionnent alors qu'on
aurait un régime général et comme un
plus bas on pourrait peut-être avoir des
recettes supérieures et rendre les
acquisitions dans certains cas plus
facile des tensions isf impôt foncier
vous savez mieux que moi mais l'impôt
foncier rapporte beaucoup plus que les
sf sans commune mesure et il y a pas de
preuves majeur avec l'impôt foncier
simplement je rappellerai que pour
l'impôt foncier
il est assis sur des bases qui ont été
établis en 1970 et qui n'ont pas été
revu depuis
donc ça correspond plus à la réalité
quand on regarde les éléments de confort
et cetera qui servent détermination
d'impôt foncier
il y a là aussi des incohérences qui ne
se comprennent pas il faudrait peut-être
y réfléchir aussi ensuite sorti du
patrimoine plus values droits de
successions et donations de neige plus
value là aussi on a un régime qui marche
assez bien ces plus values immobilières
pas depuis une réforme relativement
récente
c'est simple ça marche bien
et d'après bercy
les difficultés pour d'imposition sont
rares parce que c' est prélevé à la
source par les notaires et les recettes
engendrées sont bien supérieures aux
recettes procès antérieur
parce que il ya un prélèvement au moment
de la vente
mais il ya les plus values immobilières
ya des plus values immobilières y avait
valu présager d'art on a un patchwork là
aussi on devrait peut-être arrivé à
unifier un peu tout ça et simplifie
donations et successions et donations et
successions on à la féclaz même quelque
chose extraordinaire c'est qu'on a des
taux élevés et comment s'est rendu
compte que ces taux élevés pose des
difficultés on a mis en place des
régimes dérogatoires et les régimes
dérogatoires les a multipliées
merveilleux pour les professionnels nous
en vivons c'est très bien mais est-ce
que c'est bon pour l'état est ce que
c'est bon pour la nation que d'avoir des
impôts à taux élevés avec des assiettes
étroites
je crois me souvenir que c'est ce qu'on
me disait qu'il ne fallait pas faire
quand j'étais étudiant alors maintenant
je vais revenir à liez f descendre un
peu sur l' isf lisf est un impôt qui est
psychologiquement mal supporté par les
contribuables et les mal supporté par le
contribuable pour une raison simple
c'est que les contribuables paient
toujours avec réticence
mais p quand il ya un flux financiers
quand ya pas de flux financiers le
contribuable n'aime pas payé pourquoi la
plus value immobilière se passe
globalement bien parce que le notaire
dit au vendeur monsieur vous vendez
temps mais vous allez toucher d'anjou
fait le chèque est notaire fait le
chèque directement trésor public et ils
le voient même pas le paiement de
l'impôt
alors qu'en matière dsf n'y a pas de
flux
il faut qu'ils sortent leur chambre et
ça à tort ou à raison le contribuable
n'aime pas il n'aime pas et c'est un
impôt et psychologiquement pas supporté
deuxièmement c'est un impôt qui est
compliquée et qui fait la joie des
professionnels et c'est un impôt qui
pour éviter des dérapages trop grand a
mis en place des dérogations notamment
nécessaire au niveau de l'outil de
travail
mais on est rendant des complications
épouvantable sur les holdings actif part
active au titre à weiss qui est
nécessaire ce qui est pas nécessaire
c'est formidable je veux dire nous en
rêvons tous tout ça mais et c'est normal
et c'est nécessaire parce que s'il n'y
avait pas ça ce serait une catastrophe
mais pourquoi at on fait ça c'est parce
que on se rendait bien compte qu'on ne
pouvait pas assujettis à l'impôt sur la
fortune sur le l'outil productif et
comme on ne pouvait pas le faire en
affaires régime dérogatoire
donc je pense qu'il ya vice de base et
vis à vis fondamental au départ et si
bien que l'impôt sur la fortune est la
cause première de la délocalisation des
gens et contrairement à ce qu'on lit ce
qu'on dit et ce que bercy déclare bercy
déclare qu'il ya peu de délocalisation
et déclare qu y en a trois ou quatre
cents par an mais ce que bercy ne dis
pas parce qu'il n'a pas les statistiques
c'est qu'ils parlent des gens qui se
délocalise qui étaient assujettis à
l'impôt sur la fortune et ne parle pas
des gens qu'on délocalise dans kde
l'égalité républicaine avant de vendre
leur entreprise et qui n'étaient pas
assujettis à leur imposera fortune
qu'est ce qu'ils font
qu'est ce qu'on leur dit vous allez
vendre
vous allez payer un impôt sur les plus
belles
demain matin vous paierez alain agnès f
ils prennent le talent y ils vont à
bruxelles
ils s'installent ils vendent ensuite
leurs entreprises ils payent ni plus
value ni isf
voilà ta liste a dit voilà enfin je peux
aussi servir délocaliser et par le
thalys et tous ces gens s tous ces gens
ne rentrent pas dans les statistiques
parce qu'ils n'y étaient pas assujettis
avant c'était ce sont des chefs
d'entreprise qu'à 99 % leur patrimoine
c'était l'entreprise s'était
essentiellement ça si je fais une
extrapolation quitte une extrapolation
théorique contestable que j'ai déjà fait
devant un homme
notre commission de travail du sénat il
ya quelques années
si je prends le nombre de gens qui dans
le cadre de mort en activité ont été
délocalisés chaque année dans ce cadre
pour éviter et si je considère à peu
près la proportion de clients que je
peux avoir par rapport à la masse et
clients considèrent que c'est pas 500
mais c'est plus de 1000 parents qui
partent et ses 1000 qui partent et bien
ils ne reviendront pas parce que leurs
enfants partent aussi leurs enfants
s'installent ils vont consommer ils vont
payer l'impôt sur revenu ailleurs ils
vont payer la tva hier ils vont payer
des droits de succession ailleurs et
vont payer et ça ça fait des chiffres
considérables on prend en reparler tout
à l'heure point également important
depuis à moi on assiste concours lépine
de la fiscalité et tous les jours en a
une nouvelle mesure san conséquences et
j'ai vérifié auprès de mes amis dans je
ne sais pas chez michel taly jeu
n'ai pas parlé mais j'en ai parlé avec
francis au fait j'ai parlé avec final
pour savoir s'il était comme moi on n'a
jamais eu autant de demande de
délocalisation que depuis trois semaines
plus que dans les treize mois de l'année
précédant même des gens qui n'ont aucun
intérêt
la personne qui est un patrimoine de
800000 euros veut se délocaliser et la
peur ridicule ridicule mais il a peur
donc je pense que ce qu'il faut c'est
une règle simple et qu'on arrête le
concours lépine parce que c'est
dramatique et et d'autre part il faut
face à simplifier cette fiscalité parce
que je terminerai mon propos là dessus
il résulte différents sondages que 75 %
des français considèrent les impôts
comme injuste et trop peu important or
50 % des français ne payent pas l'impôt
sur le revenu 98 % des français ne
payent pas l'impôt sur la fortune
95% des français ne paye pas droits de
succession et pourtant deux tiers tôt
que les impôts sont trop lourds
ça signifie quoi c'est que notre
fiscalité est à bout de souffle
ça signifie que les français ne
comprennent plus c'est ea ne l'acceptent
plus heures la fiscalité nécessaire à la
démocratie
et s'il n'y a pas non plus d'adhésion à
l'impôt la démocratie est en jeu et je
pense qu'on en est arrivé là aujourd'hui
rejet de l'impôt par les citoyens et je
pense que l'impôt soit fortune y
contribue pour une part non négligeable
on peut reprendre d'autres exemples
pratiques je vous remercie
merci m alors on poursuit dans leur
alphabet tic
monsieur gervais morel
le président j'aborderai mon propos par
l' isf et le bouclier fiscal
avant de faire le parallèle avec l'impôt
sur le revenu en matière d'impôt sur la
fortune
je me montrerai très pragmatique en
constatant que l'allemagne l'autriche le
danemark la belgique irlande le royaume
uni le portugal l'italie les pays-bas la
suède l'espagne ont tous ou supprimées
ou jamais mis en place l'impôt sur la
fortune
autant de terre d'accueil à nos portes
pour les patrimoines importants et je
rappellerai que en matière de patrimoine
on allait très gros patrimoines
est ce que j'appelle moi l'esprit car de
l'usf carnet toujours le smicard de
quelqu'un le smicard du sfc celui qui à
un patrimoine d'un million de millions
d'euros celui là un patrimoine 80% en
immobilier 20% en placements financiers
celui-là est obligé de rester peut pas
partir avec ses immeubles sous le bras à
moins de tous les céder avant de partir
et puis vous avez les très très gros
patrimoines qui eux sont à 80% en
support financier et 15 ou 20 %
seulement en immobilier et ce sont ces
très gros patrimoines qui font partie de
nos statistiques concernant l'exil
fiscal
il est très facile de transférer son
patrimoine financier simple ordre de
virement quelques secondes
des centaines de millions d'euros ans
passés dans un pays proche du nôtre de
l'union européenne et la délocalisation
ne pose aucune difficulté donc en étant
pragmatique je dirais que la france ne
peut pas rester le dernier des mohicans
car c'est aujourd'hui le dernier des
mohicans en europe avec son impôt sur la
fortune
indépendamment de l'aspect moral des
choses là c'est l'aspect pragmatique
la deuxième chose que je
vous lui indiquez concerne le bouclier
fiscal depuis 2006 mise en place du
bouclier fiscal
j'avoue avoir une montée d'adrénaline
toutes les fois qu'un journaliste ou un
homme politique parle du bouclier fiscal
car en matière de bouclier fiscal on
nous explique qu'il plafonne l'impôt à
50% des revenus
mais on ne dit jamais de quel revenu il
s'agit
or vous savez qu'il ya trois types de
revenus en france il ya le revenu qu'on
déclare eia le revenu sur lequel on paye
l'impôt
je prendre un tout petit exemple et je
veux pas en développer plus et on
passait à l'époque un article dans le
figaro qui était issue une conférence
faite à patrimonia et dont le thème
était la france nouvel eldorado fiscale
un contribuable qui aurélie patrimoine
aliéné son patrimoine pour obtenir une
rente à titre onéreux encaissé à partir
de 70 ans a un revenu réel 200 revenu
taxé de 30 et son bouclier est à 15 à 15
% de son revenu réel qu'on ne dise pas
que le bouclier plafonne à 50% des
romans sur une idée à redon je prends un
deuxième exemple mais sans entrer dans
le détail
j'avais passé un article sur le sujet
qui s'appelait stratégie patrimoniale
jeu donnait l'exemple d'un contribuable
chef d'entreprise qui venait de vendre
son affaire il avait vendu plusieurs
millions d'euros se retrouve l isf eh
bien on lui donnait toutes les pistes à
explorer pour grâce au bouclier
supprimer l' isf est pratiquement
l'impôt sur le revenu schématiquement il
avait trois cent mille euros de revenus
réels financier et sa base imposable les
tec de 76 mille euros soit un impôt
global de 35000 euros environ
san imposition globale était de 11,20 %
de ses revenus réels bouclier fiscal à
50% avez vous dit c'était seulement 11%
pas un seul pays en europe ne pouvait
offrir un mécanisme
aussi efficace mais réservé à qui à ceux
qui n'ont pas d'activité à ceux qui
n'ont pas de revenus du travail
simplement à ceux qui vivent du revenu
de leur patrimoine immobilier financier
où notre système fiscal permet de créer
des distorsions colossal entre le revenu
que l'on déclare et leurs revenus que
l'on encaisse pour moi le bouclier
fiscal est un mauvais mécanisme réservé
à quelques privilégiés qui surtout ne
travaille pas des vives de ce patrimoine
immobilier financiers donc pour moi la
réponse est claire lisf devrait être
supprimé et le bouclier fiscal dans la
foulée et alors c'est un mécanisme
incompréhensible pour beaucoup et qui
est réservé à une population qu'on a
voulu conserver en france et qui depuis
2008 a repris l'exil fiscal puisque
c'est + 14 %
la raison est très simple on est dans un
pays où l'instabilité fiscale est
permanente et les gros contribuables qui
souhaiteraient rester probablement en
france savent que d'une année sur
l'autre on va modifier les règles du jeu
c'est ainsi que le bouclier fiscal sont
détricotage et déjà commencé et ce
qu'ils avaient mise en place des
stratégies patrimoniales axé sur
l'activation du bouclier fiscal ont bien
compris que ce bouclier n'aurait pas
l'efficacité qu'on leur avait annoncé
lors de sa mise en place
alors supprimer l' isf supprimé le
bouclier fiscal
comment trouver les ressources
nécessaires qui sont pas aussi élevés
que ce que j'ai pu entendre à gauche et
à droite puisque l' isf
je pense que vous connaissez même pas 3
milliards et demi j'avais noté le
chiffre alors ses premiers liens et demi
donc à vous enlever les 4 milliards sur
la conséquence du redressement fait sur
les liste hsbc c'est à dire à peu près
600 millions donc le chiffre qu'il
faudra remplacer ne nous auront pas la
pilule alors il ya la restitution qui
seraient supprimés du bouclier qui fait
700 millions d'euros environ
donc l'impact mecque de la différence
alors où trouver mais monsieur marini
jap que j'apporte ma pierre à l'édifice
en lui disant comment je broie la
contrepartie est la contrepartie la
contrepartie je la vois au niveau de
l'impôt sur le revenu le 21ème rapport
du conseil des impôts qui remonte déjà
pas mal d'années dénonçait notre système
fiscal et en des termes particulièrement
sévère en levant le par sa complexité
par sony n'ait quitté son inégalité
moi j'ai l'habitude de dire qu'on est
dans un système fiscal en france où ce
95 % des contribuables subissent l'impôt
5 % choisissent et le choisissent grâce
à maître monassier api refaire nous et
des cours et des conseillers et des
conseillers spécialisés d'entre dans ce
genre de choses on a donc quelque chose
qui colle plus vous disiez tout à
l'heure qu'une déclaration de revenus
fonciers devenue incompréhensible
la déclaration fait huit pages j'ai
appris que bercy mettait même au poids
nouveau 2042 de quatre pages rien que
poursuivre l'an prochain le régime
scellier
on a cette année une 2042 supplémentaire
pour tous les dispositifs dom tom
donc aujourd'hui la déclaration de base
2040 de quatre pages la complémentaire
six pages la complémentaire dom tom
quatre pages on attend encore quatre
pages de plus pour le scellier à partir
de 2011
c'est vrai que on est dans un système
incompréhensible
je rentre maintenant dans le détail si
on devait remettre à plat l'impôt sur le
revenu il faudrait commencer par le
quotient familial
là aussi on est le dernier des mohicans
la plupart des grands pays développés
ont fait leur réforme fiscale
le système du quotient familial a été
mise en place après la guerre pour
alléger l'impôt et aider ceux qui
auraient des enfants c'est les fameuses
demi parts additionnelles ou quotient de
base qui vont vous permettre de réduire
la progressivité de l'impôt donc votre
facture fiscale parce que vous avez des
enfants élevés au jeu je prends deux
chiffres un contribuable marié avec deux
enfants
consciente base de par deux demi-parts
additionnel on va l'aider en diminuant
sa facture fiscale avec deux 2001 avec
deux demi-parts il va en retirer un gain
fiscal de 1339 euros pour deux enfants
un contribuable son voisin même palier
il a soixante quinze mille euros de
revenus nets imposables deux fois plus
de revenus
et pour lui le gain d'impôt pour les
deux enfants à charge sera de 6600 95
euros comment peut-on expliquer parce
que j'ai un revenu deux fois plus élevée
que mon voisin que mon gain d'impôt pour
mes deux enfants soit trois fois plus
important je vais pas les nourrir neuf
fois par jour parce que j'ai trois fois
plus de revenus que mon voisin donc la
première pour moi la première réforme
qu'on pourrait faire et que beaucoup de
pays ont déjà fait ses rangs supprimer
le quotient familial
le remplacer par un mécanisme de crédit
d'impôt qui permettrait à tous ceux qui
élèvent des enfants de recevoir une aide
de l'état absolument identiques et
sortir des mécanismes complexes qui font
aussi une partie de notre activité avec
le plafonnement des effets du quotient
familial que 1 % des contribuables je
pense peut-être a réussi à décrypter
au delà d'un certain seuil de revenus la
deuxième chose que sur laquelle on
pourrait peut-être réfléchir c'est une
remise à plat et là je rejoins
complètement monsieur faire nous tous
source d'enrichissement devrait subir un
barème identique
par ailleurs on a dans notre système
fiscal c'est la france tout à fait la
france les avantages acquis on ne touche
pas aux avantages acquis je prends tout
petit exemple un salarié gagne 100 il
est imposé sur 90 on lui enlève 10% pour
ses frais professionnels
logique il feint déplacements domicile
lieu de travail
il peut même opté pour ses frais réels
un retraité
même s'il ya un plafonnement global au
niveau du foyer conserve l'abattement de
10 % pour frais professionnels
je me demande quels sont les frais
professionnels des retraités et ça c'est
un avantage acquis personne n'ose y
toucher on devrait supprimer les 10%
j'aborde ensuite la partie qui me paraît
la plus importante
comment peut-on expliquer dans notre
système fiscal
un contribuable qui travaillent payent
l'impôt jusqu'à la tranche marginale de
41% et qu'un contribuable qui vit
exclusivement de ses revenus financiers
le payent l'impôt coteaux de 19% un
différentiel de 22 points
alors on va me dire oui mais si la silla
du patrimoine financier c'est parce
qu'il a travaillé avant déjà payé
l'impôt constituer cette épargne c'est
vrai pour certains c'est de plus en plus
difficile
mais pour moi le prélèvement libératoire
devraient être il arrive à la grève et
tous ramenés dans l'assiette une
assiette unique taxable alto identique
pour tous les contribuables
tout à fait tout à fait et là ce serait
une véritable courageuse et véritable
réforme qui serait enfin entreprises sur
les plus values les plus values je vais
terminer monsieur le président sur les
plus values c'est une source
d'enrichissement
je ne vois pas pour quelles raisons les
plus values sur valeurs mobilières même
les plus values immobilières
quitte à mettre quelques mécanismes
simples d'ajustement ne subirait pas la
même imposition que les revenus du
travail
on est dans un pays dans lequel les
revenus du travail seront fortement
fiscalisés
pour ceux qui ont des revenus élevés
bien sûr mais qui est souvent la
contrepartie dans le travail important
et on a un système fiscal qui est
incroyablement favorable pour les
revenus du capital immobilier financiers
je reviens sur ce que disait monsieur
faire nous il ya quelques minutes
il parlait de l'amortissement sur les
locations en meublé et les disait gron
peut pas amortir les immeubles loués
vides dans les revenus fonciers c'est un
peu technique
moi je suis quand même assez étonné
qu'on puisse amortir un bien comme
l'immobilier
une raison extrêmement simple
l'amortissement c'est la constatation de
la dépréciation d'un bien je peux vous
dire qu'on est des rares pays dans
lequel on constate la dépréciation d'un
bien qui s'apprécient tous les ans dans
la majorité des cas et là il ya quelque
chose qui me paraît assez curieux et
dont le fondement reste un peu
mystérieux je vous dirais même que les
loueurs en meublés pour non
professionnels amortissent leurs
immeubles
et quand ils le vendent le fait de
l'avoir amorti n'a pas d'impact sur le
calcul de leurs plus values encore une
niche fiscale simple et très efficace
je vous remercie monsieur merci les vous
rendez compte que ce que vous mettez en
cause la c c'est un travail
parlementaire minutieux minutieux des
amendements multiples et alors on prend
le thalys pour pour délocaliser une
partie de son patrimoine
mais pour y voir clair on écoute
monsieur attali
dis donc je vais je vais essayer de ne
pas répéter ce qui a été dit et pour au
moins pour la particule que je partage
première question faut-il supprimer l'
isf ou plus exactement
est-ce que nous avons des finalités de
politique fiscale qui justifie qu'on
garde un impôt sur la fortune dans la
panoplie de notre système fiscal actuel
alors pour résumer puis je vais quand
même un petit peu justifiées y à titre
purement personnel j'ai quand même été
associé à cette réflexion depuis depuis
assez longtemps
je dirais de 75 à 80 j ai cru en 82 j'ai
eu des doutes et en 88 j'ai cessé
définitivement d'y croire pourquoi de 75
à 80 je faisais partie de l'équipe qui
sous la direction d'andré boulloche
d'abord laurent fabius après a conçu
l'impôt sur la fortune en compte fiscal
du ps et comme on ne concevait à
l'époque
à l'époque on essayait de remplir toutes
les finalités classique dans la peau sa
fortune réduire les inégalités de
patrimoine poussé à l'allocation
optimale des actifs ça c'est l'idée des
économistes si j'ai un impôt qui est
forfaitaire sur un bien je suis obligé
de chercher les investissements les plus
rentables et troisièmement corriger les
imperfections d'impôt sur le revenu
c'est l'impôt qu'on avait conçu et à
l'époque bon on était juste après mai 68
je veux dire forcer à vendre un bien
parce que je peux pas payer d'impôts
avec des revenus
ça nous émeut vais pas trop bon mais ça
c'est la logique d'un impôt sur la
fortune
et puis en plus le pays était pas dans
une mondialisation comme maintenant on
percevait - la concurrence fiscale entre
les états et en plus en avait pas des
instances européennes qui sans arrêt
nous disait vous avez pas le droit de
faire s'il n'a pas le droit de faire ça
par exemple l'avoir fiscal précompte
mobilier sont un système techniquement
formidable que la cour de justice de
luxembourg nous a obligés à supprimer
alors que je peux vous dire que depuis
qu'elle plus de précompte mobilier
l'optimisation fiscale raciale est
beaucoup plus facile bah oui mais on
peut passer l'europe qui veut pas donc à
l'époque 75 80 on y croyait enfin 80
alors là j'ai toujours vécu ça de
l'intérieur puisque j'étais chargé du
bureau coordination de la loi fiscale
on arrive au parlement avec un projet de
loi ou la seule exonérations biens
professionnels c'est ce qu'on appelait
l'outil de travail
l'outil de travail c'était uniquement
une deuxième un deuxième abattement à la
base pour les entrepreneurs individuels
pour tenir compte du fait qu'ils avaient
besoin d'un capital alors que les
salariés n'avaient pas besoin à revenu
égal mais y'avait pas d'exonération des
lignes de titres
pour les entreprises familiales dès le
printemps 82 première leçon de réalisme
ou de culture de gouvernement je sais
pas comment il faut dire bon lefranc
attaquer tout un tas le fait que comme
l'a dit m ou monassier cet impôt était
quand même assez mal supporté bon en
suspens en catastrophe
l'imposition sur les biens
professionnels définit comme les lignes
de titres
quand on a plus de 25% aecon exercent
des activités dirigées auxerre on les
suspend par simple décision
ministérielle et le parlement est amené
à ratifier en catastrophe tout de suite
après donc déjà un impôt qui se donnait
comme finalité de diminuer les
inégalités de patrimoine et qui
exemptent les plus riches c'est à dire
ceux qui ont les entreprises parce que
c'est quand même bon il faut pas oublier
que c'est des entreprises c'est elle qui
crée de la richesse 1 s'est fait qu'il
créent de l'emploi
mais c'est elle aussi qui effectivement
quand ça marche enrichissent le mieux
ceux qui ont osé prendre ce risque et
qui se sont pas trompés donc déjà la
finalité inégalités finalité
meilleure allocation d actifs en même
temps on a fait des abattements
d'assiette sur tous les actifs qui
avaient des rendements très faibles
c'est-à-dire 75 % d'abattement sur les
bois et forêts les baux ruraux à long
terme parce que comme ça rapporte que 1%
et paca du capital si vous taxez un
ennemi un petit problème on exonère les
oeuvres d'art pour d'autres raisons
et on s'entend donc avec une finalité
réduction des inégalités allocation
optimale qui ne fonctionne pas reste que
ça pouvait corriger à la marge les
imperfections d'impôt sur le revenu
c'est d'ailleurs une idée très cher à
pierre curie à l'époque dans le groupe
qui disait l'avantagé l'impôt sur le
capital
c'est de photographier le début de
l'année la fin de l'année c'est un
instrument d'ailleurs lui était pour un
impôt statistiques à taux très bas 0 1 %
le but étant de regarder ce qui se
passait à la posture enrhume mail à
partir du moment où tous les grands
projets ne sont pas déclarés plein de
biens sont pas déclarés
ça ne marche plus très bien là dessus
arrive 88 et donc la question de
restaurer ou pas certes impôt sur la
fortune dont j'ai vécu ça de près aussi
puisque j'étais le conseil fiscal de
michel rocard à l'époque notre première
idée était de faire la peau assiette
large taux réduit qu'à vanté m monassier
tout à l'heure et on a commencé à
essayer de voir auprès du monde des
entreprises si quel était le taux
maximal pour qu'on puisse ne pas
exonérer les biens professionnels
moi je fais ma petite tournée je suis
revenu j'ai du premier c'est 0 3% mais
dit alors on peut pas parce que 0,3 ça
restera jamais 0,3 dès qu'on aura besoin
ça sera 0 32-0 35 0 37-0 48
on restera pas 03 ça paraît tellement
faible donc on part avec un barème 05 07
il me dit faut pas dépasser important
parce que vraiment à la fois
économiquement psychiquement évidemment
la dépasser 1% au cours des débats
on a fait quelque chose d'encore plus
étonnant c'est que comme on avait une
majorité relative qu'il nous fallait des
appoints des deux côtés pour pouvoir
passer nos textes
on a concédé un côté je vous laisse
deviner lequel des taux très élevés et
on a concédé à une autre côté un
plafonnement en fonction du revenu et
donc on engendre à un monstre c'est à
dire qu'on se fait plaisir en affichant
au bon peuple des taux très élevés et on
sait que personne ne les paie bon alors
moi c'est ce jour là que j'ai cessé d'y
croire
parce que j'avais quand même pas mal
d'années derrière moi où j'avais
travaillé ce truc là et j'ai dit ça ne
marche pas ça ne marche pas parce que un
impôt sur le stock
quand plafonne en fonction du flux n'a
aucun intérêt
sauf sauf sauf et on va le voir tout à
fait à la fin du propos oui rapide que
il peut y avoir un besoin d'un impôt sur
le stock quand même sur un sujet c'est
que quand on réfléchit aux contreparties
je suis premier sf comme enjeu le
compense jeu le compense bien sûr par
une imposition du revenu du capital sur
les mêmes il s'agit pas de trouver 3
milliards sur d'autres choses sur la
peau sont venus en général il s'agit
bien puisque le seul intérêt que à cet
impôt actuellement malgré sa
monstruosité c'est de faire payer 3
milliards d'euros aux cinq cent mille
foyers qui sont quand même considérés
comme les plus favorisés dans
les chéquiers social français il faut si
possible qu'on retrouve les 3 milliards
sur les mêmes pas individuellement sinon
c'est pas la peine mais sur la même
catégorie et moi au début je pensais que
ce serait facile et je commençais à
regarder les dépenses fiscales les
choses et machin c'est à dire que avec
mes petits moyens
n'ayant pas accès à la base de données
j'ai fait ce que votre rapporteur
général a dû faire depuis plusieurs
semaines et c'est compliqué pourquoi
parce que un impôt sur le revenu
contrairement à ce qu'on dit partout et
ce qu'on a entendu ici le problème
l'impôt sur revenu pour les très riches
c'est pas un problème de taux c'est un
problème d'assiette pourquoi parce que
la différence de taux
j'ai bien entendu la différence de
revenus causée non cause et qui pourrait
justifier contact plus le capital mais
il ya des différences dans ce sens
inverse
il ya l'inflation qui fait que sur une
plus value immobilière sur 25 ans si
vous tenez pas compte de l'inflation
il ya un petit problème d'équité vous
avez le coupon obligataire qui vous
reconstitue votre capital quand vous
avez un coupon à 4 et une inflation à 2
y a que la moitié qui est une capacité
contributive au sens de la déclaration
de l'homme du site web il y a que la
moitié qui est une capacité créative le
reste c'est la reconstitution de votre
capital pour les dividendes vous avez le
prendre de le cumul entre l'impôt sur
les sociétés et l'impôt sur le revenu
alors il ya des pays qui n'efface pas ce
cumul comme les américains mais ils
n'ont pas les mêmes taux d'imposition
que nous il y en a d'autres qui les
fasse est totalement nous on le fasse
partiellement bon on ne peut pas ne pas
en tenir compte
alors en revanche le vrai problème
d'assiette c'est que et il est lié à
l'échec du plafonnement du bouclier tout
ce que vous voulez c'est que les plus
riches leurs revenus ces des dividendes
et quand vous avez 80 millions de
dividendes 40 millions de dividendes ou
200 millions de dividendes
vous avez pas besoin de tout ça pour
vivre même si vous filmez beaucoup pour
lesquels les cigarettes sont chères
faisait pas besoin de tout ça donc
qu'est ce que vous faite de cet argent
ben vous le laisser dans des holdings
intermédiaires et ça c'est pas de l'abus
de droit on a le droit de ne pas se
distribuer et donc on apprenne
d'accumulation du capital
alors là les gens qui raisonnent bien
c'était aux américains disent on va
taxes
les revenus accumulés dans les
structures intermédiaires alors que nous
on entend dire le contraire en ce moment
on entend des gens qui nous disent il
faudrait moins taxer les revenus l'on
distribue que les revenus distribués
la vérité c'est que si on veut être
juste il faut faire l' inverse il faut
les taxer
il faut les taxer et donc il ya deux
façons de faire sur les taxes comme ça
sans les taxes comme font les
néerlandais mehdi façon peut-être moins
globale ce serait d'avoir une taxation
sur le stock de capital financier et
regarder soi forfaitairement comme les
néerlandais
je taxe 3% 4 % au taux moyen de 25 ou
30% comme le font le néerlandais soit
d'avoir
une taxation un peu plus au réel qui est
de taxer l'accroissement après tout à
l'impôt sur les sociétés comment
définit-on le revenu ont défini leur
venue comme la différence de deux stocks
le stock au début de l'année et le stock
à la fin de l'année hélas ce moment là
effectivement on a quelque chose qui est
un peu plus équitable parce qu'on arrive
à toucher les titres de plus revenu moi
j'ai lu le livre de monsieur piketty je
suppose que vous le regardez tous en ce
moment on va beaucoup parler à mon avis
au début 2012
piketty il considère que le problème est
résolu parce qu'ils taxes des
contribuables virtuel c'est que sa macro
économiste et crédit ou économique
c'est à dire que surtout ils taxent un
contribuable qui serait un très riche
qui se distribuent ray tout est alors
élu augmente le taux qui se disputent
renouer et qu'il ne chercherait pas
quitter le territoire
parce qu'après on le taxe à 60% de taux
moyen de taxes à 60% de taux moyen sur
20 millions encore mieux en 81 kg ont
des professions alors là effectivement
ça rapporte de l'argent
mais même si même si une majorité voté
demain un taux de 60 pour cent en taux
effectif
il n'aurait toujours pas la base parce
qu'il n'aurait pas résolu le problème
que les gens ne se distribue pas
l'argent
donc c'est pas un problème de taux c'est
un problème d'assiette et inversement
lisf sauraient pas est un problème
d'assiette si on avait été raisonnable
sur le taux donc voilà les quelques
réflexions personnelles je voulais vous
livre
messieurs pour ces quatre contributions
qui éclairent notre réflexion sur la
fiscalité du patrimoine est consciente
nous sommes que ça n'est pas simple non
plus que de ne traiter qu'un aspect de
la fiscalité car la fiscalité est un
tout et on ne peut pas isoler patrimoine
revenu et consommation bien et bien vous
êtes des praticiens donc quand on parle
de délocalisation de de patrimoine vous
en avez vu en tout cas ce n'est pas une
fiction parce que tant de temps ou du
melon spacieux importante ça n'existe
pas bon voilà ça existe et il faisait le
sentiment que depuis quelques semaines
ça reprend ça reprend encore tout ce
qu'on aime c'est que on a souligné mes
amis ont souligné une chose très vrai il
ya eu un rapport sous la présidence du
de l'ancien président la commission des
finances du sénat
olivier fouquet équidés
oui absolument on parle d'un ballon du
conseil d'état s'est jamais fait élire
sénateur allons mais du conseil d'état
est ou non je ne dira pas si simple
tout le monde connaît olivier fouquet on
sait très bien qu'il est au conseil
d'état je vous remercie d'avoir rectifié
mais il a on lui a demandé un rapport
sur hawks il ya quatre ans maintenant
sur justement là le problème qu'on a
cessé de soulever qui est celui de la
confiance légitime dans le système et
olivier vous qu'elle concluait dans ce
rapport avec les membres de la
commission que tout texte fiscal doivent
avoir au moins une pérennité de cinq ans
et est ce que ça c'est suivi s'est
jamais suivi et on tombe sur ce que
disait monsieur monaci avec juste raison
la personne ne sait plus où elle va donc
elle et localise et une fois qu'elle est
de localiser jamais elle reviendra
pourquoi parce qu on lui prend un
bouclier fiscal et puis après trois ans
80 premiers débats non il n'y en a plus
mais on maintient quand même y est c'est
fait alors il comprend alors comment
voulez vous qu'ils comprennent quelque
chose et puis surtout je confirme tout à
fait ce que dit à monsieur monassier
parce que faut pas parler des gens
qu'ils délocalisent faut parler des gens
qui anticipent les plus values parce que
les gens partent avant ils partent pas
maintenant qu'il ya beaucoup ils sont
partis il ya des exemples célèbres qui
sont partis avant tout problème de
boucles
eddy est fatigué parce qu'ils ont
anticipé la vente de leur entreprise
tout simplement et monsieur mono j avais
mis à passer maintenant à la phase
question est la parole de tous
rapporteur général beaucoup monsieur le
président que comme vous l'avez dit très
justement nous ont été éclairés pour
autant avant nous avancer sur le chemin
d'une réforme
après vous avoir très attentivement
écouté je n'en suis pas certain je n'en
suis pas certain j'ai beaucoup apprécié
en particulier à dernière intervention
le coming out de michel taly qui a été
particulièrement brillant comme à son
ordinaire et je lui ferai une remarque
et une confidence si on me le permet la
remarque c'est que notre fiscalité
serait meilleur michel si tu n'avais pas
été socialiste à 20 ans et manon propos
complémentaires ma confidence ces deux
pour ma part je suis devenu
mitterrandien sur un point comme je
pense que l'on ne supprimera pas l' isf
je suis très attaché à la conception
d'une exonération totale des biens
professionnels avec la vision la plus
large possible et d'une exonération des
oeuvres d'art si l'on ne veut pas
favoriser l'hémorragie artistique de
notre pays et donc sur ces deux points
ce sont des échanges je suis devenu
totalement mitterrandien et je reconnais
la grande sagesse du président que nous
avons vu au moins sur cet aspect
maintenant je voudrais poser une
question est ce que ça a un sens de se
livrer à cet exercice
je veux dire est ce que cela a un sens
j'oppose à tous la question est ce que
cela a un sens de dire je vais faire la
réforme de l'impôt sur le patrimoine
sans envisager ou sans exprimer une
vision claire
de la réforme fiscale globale d'ailleurs
chacun dans vos interventions
quand vous êtes entré sur le domaine
délicat des contreparties parce qu'on ne
peut naturellement pas se payer deux
fois de suite la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle qui a alourdi le déficit
de 5 milliards d'euros par an et qui de
ce point de vue est irresponsable
irresponsable comme on ne peut pas après
la crise
refaire ce même exercice il faut trouver
des contreparties je vous ai tous écouté
et je pose donc la question est ce que
cela a un sens de vouloir faire une
réforme qui soit une vraie réforme de
l'impôt sur le patrimoine sans la placer
dans le cadre cohérent d'une stratégie
fiscale
est-ce qu'on peut traiter le sujet de la
fiscalité des possédants sans se poser
la question de la société dans laquelle
on veut se trouver et du modèle fiscal
qui doit la représenter donc je serais
heureux que chacun puisse apporter sa
vision et sa sensibilité sur ce point de
principe maintenant et et s'agissant des
deux éventualités qui sont devant nous
l'une c'est finalement de partir de ce
que nous faisons au lieu de l'hémicycle
n'avons cessé de demander en 2008 en
2009 en 2010 nous avons dit faut faire
trois choses
supprimer l'isf supprimer le bouclier
fiscal et à due concurrence relevée le
rendement de l'impôt sur le revenu
éventuellement procéder à quelques
ajustements et donc et
cette réforme qui serait une réforme
majeure je me répète
est-ce qu'elle a un sens déconnecté
d'une stratégie fiscale globale
ensuite si l'on cherche à être
constructif parce que nous besogneux de
l'hémicycle et de l'amendement
nous nous confrontons réalité comme le
jeune michel taly conseiller ministériel
s'est confronté à la réalité d'une
majorité plurielle avec l'un qui
demandait une chose et l'autre une autre
incompatibles qu'est-ce que ça conduit à
quoi cela conduit un compromis le
compromis est dans notre culture
institutionnelle parlementaire donc il
ya fort à parier que si l'on continue
sur cette affaire difficile et
périlleuse on aboutir à un compromis
alors ce compromis est ce que vous le
sentez est ce que le fait de sortir de
l' isf les riches qui ne sont pas riches
c'est à dire la première tranche de
régler par là même la question très
épidermique de la résidence principale
pour un très grand nombre de personnes
est ce que le fait de supprimer le
bouclier fiscal et ses perversités dans
une période de remontée des taux
d'imposition ce que c'est la période où
deux les taux de prélèvements
obligatoires
ne nous voilons pas la face c'est la
période dans laquelle nous sommes
est-ce que la suppression du bouclier
fiscal avec comme seule contrepartie
leur tour un plafonnement raisonnable
qui serait le plafonnement de 1988
est-ce que donc cet aménagement avec
pour contrepartie des ajustements
reposant sur les mêmes pour à peu près
les mêmes économiquement socialement les
mêmes comme ceci a été dit est ce que
ceci vous semble faisable et dans ce
cadre s'agissant des contreparties à
trouver pour un montant total un enjeu
qui serait sans doute de l'ordre de 1,5
milliard d'euros compris entre 1,5 et 2
donc dans le cadre de cet exercice
quels sont vos préconisations je ne
prétends pas
vous disant cela que c'est la formule
qui sera choisi mais pour moi elle
paraît probable parce que donc
connaissant un peu la pratiquer le jeu
des différentes forces
c'est une sorte de compromis vers lequel
pour des raisons assez évidente
nous serons tentés de nous diriger donc
si nous faisions cela ce que je ne
considérais pas comme merveilleux mais
comme utile donc ne pouvant pas être
rejetés parce que tout part en avant est
un bon pas donc si l'on faisait cela les
contreparties ou faudrait-il les trouver
puis toute dernière question pardonnez
moi ce n'est pas la flèche du parthe
mais toute dernière question compte tenu
de l'état d'esprit de vos clients et de
l'insistance que l'on met souvent à
juste titre a parlé d' instabilité
fiscale
est-ce qu'il faut vraiment faire quelque
chose en 2011 1
et est-ce qu'on va y croire je veux dire
est ce qu une réforme faite par une
majorité dont l'espérance de vie ce
raccourci chaque jour d'une journée 1 et
qui est en butée sur une échéance qui
est fatal est-ce que ce que fait une
majorité dans ces conditions-là inspire
réellement confiance voilà inspirera
confiance chez vos clients
voilà donc vous nous documentons riez et
les uns et les autres si vous acceptez
de répondre à ces questions sans détour
est-ce que je prenais suspension pour le
déjeuner si vous pouvez le faire en
synthétique
déjà sur le sens d'une réforme séparer
évidemment tout est dans tout et
réciproquement le problème c'est que
comme le grand soir fiscal je n'ai
jamais vu il faut bien qu'on fasse des
choses la seule la seule chose qui
manque en france en général c'est que
comme on n'affiche pas assez
explicitement les finalités
on n'a jamais été capable de faire une
première étape qui soient cohérentes
avec un paysage de fonds et les rares
fois où on a dit je fais ça dans un
premier temps dans un deuxième temps je
ferai ça on n'a jamais fait et il ya
même pas eu besoin d'alternance
politique pour ça on l'a jamais fait bon
dans l'horizon fiscale gagnerait à être
décidée
donc c'est là que ce que je regrette
surtout c'est qu'on puisse pas faire des
compromis vie bipartisans à l'allemande
mais peut-être que parce que ils l'ont
pas fait par vertu il en fait à cause du
résultat des urnes ils ont peu de choix
bon donc on verra mais
le compromis ils ont été obligés de
s'engager tous sur un compromis
bipartisans ça ça pourrait donner
confiance
il ya eu un seul cas en france où on a
fait ça c'est la réduction du taux
d'impôt sur les sociétés qui a été
commencé par une majorité
poursuivi par l'autre continuez à la
nouvelle alternance et tout le monde a
bien compris qu'il y avait une
continuité donc ça effectivement il
faudrait qu'on trouve une certaine forme
de compromis évidemment c'est pas
maintenant ce sera peut-être plus tôt
après on peut toujours faire des mesures
limitées et espérait qu'elles soient
cohérentes avec ce qu'on fera après
alors sur les contreparties
moi je crois qu'on peut pas avancer si
on sépare pas complètement l'immobilier
le financier dans l'immobilier les
choses sont claires on a un revenu qui
est taxé comme les autres revenus au
barème on a des plus values avec une
taxation atténuée pour tenir compte de
l'inflation nous de façon tellement
forfaitaire qu'il ya peut-être des
choses à regarder et donc on n'a pas les
mêmes problèmes que le taux de
prélèvement libératoire bon
sur les revenus financiers en revanche
on a des problèmes de taux que tout le
monde a cité mais je maintiens qu'on a
un énorme problème sur les plus hauts
revenus du fait de la non distribution
est là et je n'ai pas les bases de
données pour cent cela pourrait
rapporter ce qui est sûr c'est que ça
peut pas se faire d'ici là l'option sera
qualificative donc effectivement je
pense que c'est difficile de faire des
choses aussi ample que celle que nous
avons les uns et les autres évoqué dans
le délai qui vous est imparti
aujourd'hui donc effectivement me
convertissant réalisme sur le tard je
pense que le truc en deux temps oui et
une réforme globale bien sûr serait
indispensable et nécessaire mais il faut
être réaliste et je ne pense pas qu'elle
soit possible actuellement
deuxièmement une réforme comme dit
monsieur rapporteur général à 1 quelques
mois d'une échéance politique je pense
que ça peut-être sur le plan
psychologique
un échec parce que on vient c'est une
réforme a minima comme celle que
monsieur rapporteur général a évoqué
si c'est une réforme a minima les gens
en france 250 mille foyers qui met la
majorité ceux qui seront un sujet
continue de retrait ce sujet qui ne
seront pas contents et est globalement
en voudront à la politique quand il aura
aux politiques qui ont fait cela et sont
viscéralement mécontents quant à ceux
qui sont pour l'impôt sur la fortune
pour des raisons politiques diverses et
variées il doit y vont dire que la
majorité actuelle a fait un cadeau à un
certain électorat
donc je crois qu'on met contentera tout
le monde à faire une réforme a minima
personne ne sera content deuxièmement
l'inquiétude restera parce que tout le
monde dira qu est ce qui va se passer
demain c'est à dire après des élections
et comme le disait michel ta vie je
pense que l'imposition sur le patrimoine
est tellement importante est tellement
de conséquence il faudrait faire un rêve
qui est un consensus politique pour
arriver à quelle finalité en dire voilà
ce qu'on veut pour l'impôt sur le
patrimoine
avec ces trois assiettes à l'entrée à la
détention et à la sortie par rapport à
la concurrence internationale qu'est ce
qu'on veut comme prélèvements sur notre
pib
à quel moment le prends comme on le
prend on peut faire un rêve mais je
pense que s'il n'y a pas de consensus
l'inquiétude ira en grandissant c'est
pour ça que j'ai parlé de concours
lépine
je parlais d'inquiétude et c'est
dramatique c'est dramatique parce que ce
sont quand on voit partir des chefs
d'entreprise ce pas les chefs
d'entreprise qui partent en eux mêmes
qui sont importants mais c'est que leurs
familles par leur argent par les enfants
partent
l'investissement se fait ailleurs et
c'est terminé
les gens ne reviendront pas et garde une
résidence secondaire à paris ou sur la
côte ou aux sports d'hiver un point
c'est tout et donc c'est des forces
vives qui s'en vont
et je crois que on a besoin de quelque
chose de simple et je crois qu à
quelques mois des élections ça me paraît
très difficile personnellement ou alors
il faudrait une union nationale là
dessus mais des rêves ne reste que des
rêves horaire oui
monsieur morel oui j'avoue être assez
mal à l'aise dans cette table ronde
je suis le régional de l'étape je veux
dire par là que je ne vis pas à paris au
milieu des cercles économistes
politiques et cetera
j'habite dans les monts du beaujolais et
on a une vision des choses qui est
sûrement moins macroéconomique macro
fiscale mais qui dans la réalité abouti
à un certain découragement ça fait 40
ans probablement le plus en jeu le plus
âgé des quatre ça fait 40 ans que
j'entends les hommes politiques nous
annoncer à chaque nouvelle législature
on va faire la réforme fiscale
ça fait 40 ans que rien n'est fait qu
aucune réforme de structure nets
entreprises et que le millefeuille
continue à s'épaissir continue à
augmenter et quand j'ai entendu monsieur
marini nous dire c'est pas possible lisf
on va pas le supprimer on va là ménagé
peut-être en enlevant la résidence
principale ou en l'enlevant si son
montant dépasse pas au delà d'un certain
seuil le bouclier vous ne pouvez pas le
supprimer dans ces conditions car il
profite à qui ils ont sait qu'il profite
au très très gros patrimoines qu'on
voudrait conserver en france et on a mis
en place ce bouclier pour éviter l'exil
fiscal on maintiendront qu'un système
qui pour moi est un système qui relève
d'une certaine escroquerie puisque je
vous rappelle je vous rappelle que quand
bercy a sorti le bouclier en 2006 il le
voyait un pli câble à 235 mille
contribuables
on sait qu'il y en a quinze mille ou
17000 qui en bénéficient elle est
conseillée que 60% la restitution est
absorbée par 6 % des contribuables
c'est à dire ceux qui ont 100 millions
d'euros de patrimoine par les smicards
de liesse f qui ont deux ou trois
millions de patrimoine on va rien régler
encore encore encore
or une tranche de mille feuille
supplémentaire je sais pas je sais pas
quoi vous répondre parce que j'ai
peut-être encore l' enthousiasme de
l'époque où je faisais mes études garder
c'est en tout cas mais je ne veux je
cite rêve un je citerai une réflexion
d'un froid d'économistes américains que
tout le monde connaît une fois de plus
on a des politiques qui pensent à la
prochaine élection
on a pas d'homme d'état qui travaille
pour la prochaine génération
est-ce que lorie sap scalent extrêmement
gênant extrêmement ennuyeux quand est ce
que les hommes politiques vont se
décider à entreprendre une vraie réforme
fiscale
on parlait des dividendes tout à l'heure
il ya une solution assez simple pour les
dividendes
je dirais pour les dividendes on avait
eu une réforme assez intelligente il ya
quelques années où le cac 40
elle a été supprimée pour éviter la
double imposition vous connaissez ce qui
avait été fait c'était pour moi très
intelligent et c'était simple lorsqu'une
société fait des bénéfices elles payent
l'impôt
lorsqu'une société distribue son
bénéfice on lui permet de déduire les
dividendes distribués elle récupère donc
l'impôt qu'elle avait payé et on me taxe
que le bénéficiaire final dans le cadre
de l'impôt sont revenus roche trouver
des recettes fiscales vous pouvez en
trouver
vous pouvez en trouver ça mais c'est
dans les vieux pots qu'on fait les
meilleures confitures
on a eu dans le passé des mécanismes qui
s'applique d'ailleurs toujours dans un
cas c'est la retenue à la source valant
crédits d'impôts ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que pour les sociétés mes
confrères parlait des holdings
intermédiaires qui permettent de stocker
des dividendes alors je stocke mais
dividende
je les appréhende pas parce que je fume
pas des à vin n'est sans doute pas assez
cher pour absorber tout mais dividende
c'était l'exemple du fumeur qui était
donné par monsieur attali je crois mais
on fait une on procède à une retenue à
la source qui permet à l'état
d'engranger des recettes fiscales
provisoire et qui serait à juste au
moment où le revenu est réellement
encaissées est là la mise en place d'une
imposition de
bâle est identique pour tous se met en
place ce système n'existe plus
aujourd'hui que pour les banques caisses
nominatifs et dieu sait que le bon de
caisse a pratiquement disparu de nos
systèmes
il a existé dans le passé sur les
revenus d'obligations ou là le fait de
décaisser un revenu d'obligations
permettait à l'état de prélever à la
source
on a eu du 12 et du 10 % et puis
lorsqu'ensuite le revenu passe dans le
barème progressif de lierre la taxation
devient définitive et la retenue à la
source est imputé sur l'impôt à payer
mécanisme très simple on pourrait
généraliser le système les très gros
patrimoines qui seraient dispensés dit
sf ne serait pas dispenser d'un minimum
d'impôt sur les revenus de ce patrimoine
et lorsqu'il se distribuerait des
dividendes qui tomberait dans un holding
intermédiaire pourquoi pas il éviterait
la taxation immédiate à lierre il
n'empêche qu'on pourrait très bien
exiger de la société distributrice une
retenue à la source
ils pourront récupérer plus tard quand
il appréhenderont ce revenu donc trouver
des ressources pour remplir les caisses
de l'état
c'est possible si on fait l'effort de se
lancer dans une véritable mais je
l'attends depuis 40 ans réforme fiscale
dit professeur puis à faire le haut s'il
vous plaît si vous voulez j'ai bien
écouté les propos de deux les
participants et les vôtres est ce
monsieur monsieur le rapporteur marini
je ne suis pas certain personnellement
je ne suis pas certains qu'aucun
consensus puisque vous parlez de
politique je suis pas certains qu'aucun
consensus ce soit possible
voilà pourquoi
si si on voulait bien adopter la
position de tous les revenus au taux
marginal
si on voulait bien ce progrès au bahreïn
en fait aux barèmes au barème si on
voulait bien se préoccuper de ce que moi
j'appelle plus globalement parce que
l'exemple de michel taly est excellent
sur les dividences que j'appelle
l'argent dormant le problème de l'argent
en dormant en france c'est une source de
revenus importante et voulait une
recette
je vous en donner une fois ci nous ont
donné une de recettes
il vous manque combien de 3 milliard et
bien moi je vous donne la solution pour
en trouver 12 tout de suite en se
préoccupant de l'argent dormant
je m'explique quel est le montant total
des encours placé dans l'assurance-vie
1200 milliards d'euros d'accords et si
on taxe cet argent dormant puisqu'on
parle de d'imposer l'argent dormant
si on pour élèves 1% des encours 1% des
encours quelqu'un qui a un contrat
d'assurance vie il est imposé au maximum
à 12 3 % d'accord sur les sur les
produits d'accord quand il retire
bon si on ajoute un pour cent si on
ajoute 1% des encours personnes qui
personnellement ne l'ait d'aucune ne
rend pas son argent utiles au
développement de l'économie
il paye 1% finance les déficits publics
ça et financé des piscines publiques
attendez c'est pas ça que je veux dire
c'est pas lui qui le fait non je suis
d'accord mais c'est pas lui qui les
kills et qu'ils utilisent l'argent c'est
pas si vous voulez c'est pas lui qui
investit dans l'économie c'est pas lui
qui investissent et cet argent dans
l'économie
c'est ça que je veux dire de même il ya
des systèmes qu'il faut quand même
auquel il faut mettre un terme
on a vu des compagnies d'assurances
mettre en place des contrats d'assurance
vie en proposant gens voilà vous vendez
votre mobilier combien vaut-il 2
millions d'euros combien vous
rapporte-t-il il vous rapporte je sais
pas moi à 10% 1 bon 1 60000 euros si
vous voulez eh bien on a dit aux gens
vous vendez vous vendez ce bien vous
mettez l'argent sur un contrat
d'assurance-vie et nous on vous assure
des retrait programmé
c'est à dire que le type reçoit les
mêmes revenus avec la fiscalité des
retrait programmé
c'est à dire qu'il va jamais payé que 3%
sur les revenus alors qu'avant ils
paient quoi les revenus sur les revenus
du capital procurés par les immeubles
donnés en location et grâce à ce système
il sort complètement de l'économie et il
est imposée de façon absolument ridicule
avec des retraites programmée c'est à
dire janvier et en février tombe ou par
trimestre 1 située tout par année et ses
programmes et à la danse
donc le type a vendu ce qui était
productif
il a placé son argent à dents et puis
ils encaissent les revenus y paye une
fiscalité absolument ridicule au maximum
à payer 3% sur les revenus voilà ce qui
va se passer
donc le problème de l'argent dormant de
la personne ce que je veux dire
pour être en phase avec michel tanner
d'un personnes qui n'utilisent pas
elle-même son argent pour d une
opération productive elle même si vous
voulez il ya un problème quelque part
mais je suis d'oeil grâce et un peu tout
où toutes les spécificités fiscales de
l'ehpad mise
les pe a par exemple bien sûr est ce
qu'il n'ya pas des optimisations sur les
pays acp
attendez il ya des gens qui créent très
bien mon comité des pays bas sont un
vrai scandale
man mal comité d abus de droit s'est
penché récemment sur cette question
il s'est penché sur cette question des
gens qui créent des pea actions
3 le truc non mais non mais non monsieur
leurs portes
monsieur le rapporteur a raison mais on
sait très bien que par le biais de
l'abus de droit il suffit de lire les
avis récent du comité d abidjan pour
s'apercevoir que c'est ça pas été tout à
fait utiliser d'ailleurs dans dans les
conditions le pkk fixé cette commission
des finances lors du vote du pays à
l'objectif du législateur a été
totalement détournées puisque ça devait
être pour des opérations de de création
or on crée des sortes de holding
on l'a vu des trucs absolument
incroyable avec ça et c'est parce qu'on
détourne le texte de son objet alors je
voudrais dire une dernière chose parce
que c'est une chose dont on n'a pas
parlé et qui me paraît importante parce
qu'on parle de fiscalité du patrimoine
et la fiscalité du patrimoine
on parle beaucoup des niches fiscales et
les niches fiscales ont la coutume de
dire il faut les supprimer follet
raboter frein chien bon déjà il faut
savoir qu'en gestion de patrimoine dans
le cas de la gestion de patrimoine
les principales niches fiscales c'est
quoi c'est la location meublée la loi
malraux et les monuments historiques le
constat qui peut être fait tous les
jours
section la loi malraux il y aurait plus
un centre-ville historique qui tiendrait
debout les châteaux plus personne pour
aller visiter les locations meublées
l'initiative privée prend le relais
d'initiative publique défaillante pour
la construction des maisons de retraite
pour la construction des maisons
médicalisées
ça ce sont les particuliers qui finança
donc que l'état y participe
c'est normal mais où je veux en venir
c'est qu'il faut absolument changer ces
dispositifs
parce que il s'agit de savoir qui
captent qui capte le produit du service
qu'il rend à l'état est-ce que c'est
l'investisseur s'est jamais
l'investisseur
c'est l'intermédiaire qui vont le
produit 15 % plus cher et c'est surtout
le problème des frais d'ingénierie je
vais vous donner un exemple dans votre
catalogue l'outre-mer bien sûr mais
attendez je vais vous donner un exemple
peut-être que vous n'imaginez pas j'ai
vu de mes yeux un vendeur de produits
qui faisait investir 1 million d'euros à
son client qui lui fournissait un
dossier d'ingénérie qu'ils aient 12
pages avec trois tableaux classiques
trésorerie un machin pouvant là est ce
que vous savez combien facture et ce à
quatre cent mille euros 40 % alors vous
allez me dire mais comment le tiff fait
pour accepter ça bien sûr qu'ils
acceptent pourquoi pas ce qu'on lui dit
vous allez déduire sa de votre venue
et vous paierez pas d'impôt sur le
revenu donc il faudrait encadrer ces
niches fiscales de façon que ce soit
bien l'investisseur qui en bénéficient
celui qui rend service à la collectivité
parce que ça c'est de la fiscalité
patrimoine c'est pour ça que me permets
l'escale fausse les prix progrès donc
pour en terminer je crois qu'une réforme
fiscale c'est pas sûr qu'elle soit pas
adopté parce que si on taxe l'argent
dormant
si on taxe les dividendes comme proposé
à michel ahnee si on soumet tous au taux
marginal de l'impôt c'est pas sûr qu'une
autre majorité ne ne pourraient pas
rentrer dans ce set
dans cette logique merci de de cette
vision appuyer sur vos pratiques
professionnelles et qui fait la part de
l'illusion et la réalité
mais au fond pour faire un consensus
supra partisans peut-être que le sénat
pourrait apporter sa contribution ont du
sens alors question de nos collègues
serge dassault d'abord au cidre est
dedans
ma question s'adresse surtout à mettre
mon à chier il a dit tout à l'heure qui
avait eu où il occupera par an ces
partis mais depuis combien de temps je
subis depuis 12 ans ça fait combien en
tout et surtout avec quel montant de
leur patrimoine sont partis avec eux et
s'ils auraient pas été préférable de
garder en france pour qu'ils
investissent et sur aurait rapporté plus
sûrement que la peau sur l' isf qui se
déduit qui se détruit de plus en plus
puissante base en moins et que ces
continuent viendra pu tout parce que il
y aura plus personne pour payer la peau
sur l' isf et il n'y a plus que des
pauvres en france alors là c'est là la
suppression et non pas l'aménagement dsf
ferait revenir dit je pense tout voulait
délocaliser avec leur fortune et cela je
pense qu'on pourrait largement les 3
milliards perdus si on supprime les sf
j'espère rapidement quel est le montant
total qui pourrait revenir capital qui
serait en multi de nouveaux pourraient
investir en france
si on supprime pas les sf d'autres comme
le dit mon partir puisqu'ils partent
déjà bientôt il n'y aura plus de
patrimoine en france
tous sont partis en belgique angleterre
chaud je vous rappelle que l'angleterre
les anglais ont dit que les sf était une
fin eu une vraie vraie pour eux c'était
l'équivalent du de la suppression le dit
nantes car tous les français partent à
l'étranger avec leur fortune au lieu de
rester en france comme cela a eu lieu
avec la suppression de 10 dans donc ne
recommençons pas et je crois que ce sera
plus de batterie malenfant s'investir
comprenez on dit toujours suprême m
chômage soit au chômage soit investi à
l'anr
qui va investir et qui va réduire le
chômage qui sont tous partis à
l'étranger et voit aussi peut-être sans
doute si ça continue comme ça alors on
est les seuls au monde à le faire et il
y aurait à dire que le faire partir les
riches ne profite pas aux pauvres et
c'est déjà monsieur lincoln le premier
président des tannique qu'il avait dit
et c'est toujours le cas donc supprimons
pas d'eric on a besoin des riches pour
que les beaufs puisque aussi travailler
et investir pour eux voilà la parole est
maintenant à françois marc
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
pas alimenter la séquence nostalgie mais
je trouve moi que mai 68 c'était quand
même sympa construit quoi
c'était un air nouveau qui soufflait et
puis les projets fiscaux qui
sont venus après je veux parler de mes
80 ch ou et que c'est aussi du sens sur
le plan de l'idéologie d'une certaine
philosophie de la vie de la société de
l'économie
et quand je compare les réalisations
fiscal de l'époque à celle que l'on a
aujourd'hui sous nos yeux avec le
bouclier fiscal avec les niches qui
représente des dizaines de milliards
et avec tout un ensemble de réforme de
la tp autres 5 milliard en moins pour
les recettes publiques dont je me dis
que au fond
me sf n'a peut-être pas que des vertus
mais avec son coût de 3 milliards
il a une finalité et une légitimité
relativement aux attentes de nos
concitoyens bon kivu qui vaut ce qu'elle
vaut mais qu'on ne peut pas écarter d'un
revers de main donc je pense que le
principe qui a été rappelé par monsieur
faire nous sur lequel chacun doit
contribuer à donner selon ses
possibilités contributive est
je pense pertinent et doit être rappelée
et peut permettre effectivement d'avoir
cette réflexion sur un système global
moi je ne me résigne pas à l'idée que on
ne pourrait rien faire sinon à dire
l'impôt est impopulaire donc supprimons
lisf bon si c'est ça le raccourci dans
lequel il faut s'inscrire aujourd'hui
moi j'ai sentiment que là le débat
politique à des ressorts qui ont perdu
de leur vitalité par rapport à mai 68
donc je ne me résigne pas à cet état
d'esprit donc je pense qu'une réforme
globale reste possible et que l'apport
des économistes on a parlé de piketty au
chaud que c'est bien ce qu'il fait
piketty parce que il veut rendre
accessible à tous les citoyens le débat
à partir de principes simples
alors certes c'est des grands principes
certes ça manque de pragmatisme à
certains égards mais je pense que si on
ne se
on ne reparle harris pas les questions
de fiscalité si on ne met pas sur une
base accessible aux citoyens ce débat
qui est fondamental on n'avancera pas
non plus donc je crois que la réflexion
elle est engagée elle va est alimentée
par ce travail et moi je pense qu'on
peut trouver des solutions et certaines
des pistes ont été suggérées sur le
patrimoine et sur les plus-values sur
les dividendes ou il est noté clairement
qu' aujourd'hui une situation de fait
parce que avantageuse pour certains on a
parlé des smicards aussi de lier c'est
fond c'est vrai que tout ça il faut
l'avoir en tête et moi je pense qu'il ya
un certain nombre de dévolution sur
lesquels on peut arriver à se mettre
d'accord au parlement en tout cas c'est
dans cet esprit que nous on va
travailler faire des propositions et
aussi sur l'impôt sur les sociétés où il
ya véritablement aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de choses aberrantes quand on
voit distinction majeure qui entre le
comportement à la sélection faite aux
pme et la situation faite aux cas car en
nous on est a introduit pour 110 et de
l'impôt société alors pour les pme on
est proche des 33
on se dit qu'il ya quelque part là aussi
un dysfonctionnement majeur et donc moi
je reste persuadé je fasse optimiste sur
notre capacité collective à faire
partager la préoccupation et essayer de
trouver les solutions qui vont avoir non
pas de la popularité mais en tout cas un
assentiment assez large de notre
population vous encourageant convergence
de d'objectifs rassemblement marie
france beaufils pour confirmer cette
bonne impression
c'est pas si je fais confirmer la bonne
impression
moi je voudrais dire que j'ai j'ai
apprécié dans ce que vous avez dit parce
que les uns et les autres vous vous avez
importé quelque part des éléments de
réflexion qui m'amène à dire en effet
qu'il faut vraiment faire une refonte
complète de notre régime d'imposition en
france mais quand on parle d'un position
c'est pas uniquement l'imposition sur le
patrimoine
enfin moi je le ressens comme tel je
crois qu'on a un véritable problème mais
qu'on a aussi une autre question qui est
posée si à quoi sert l'impôt moi je veux
bien aujourd'hui on nous dit il ya un
rejet de l'impôt on a contribué à faire
rejeter l'impôt et l'ensemble des
pratiques politiques de ces de ces
dernières années ont largement contribué
en considérant que et je tendais
monsieur dassault parler que parce que
on a quelque part une contribution à la
vie économique par sa richesse on ne
devrait pas payer plus d'impôts this y
ont par ce qu'on contribue à cette
richesse je m'excuse les salariés y
contribuent ils payent un impôt qui
s'appelle la tva qui n'a rien de
proportionnelle avec leurs ressources et
ça on le met on le met de côté celui là
donc moi je j'aurais tendance à dire que
je trouverai quand même intéressant que
les uns et les autres si on veut trouver
des formes de réponse
on se pose la question comment l'impôt
que l'on met en oeuvre pèse sur tous les
types de populations qui sont concernés
parce qu'on peut pas par
deux d'un seul type d'impôt sinon on est
quand même à des difficultés mais aussi
qu'on se pose la question comment
l'imposition elle est incitative à la
politique que l'on veut mener dans le
pays
on peut pas détacher les choix
d'imposition de des choix politiques que
l'on fait sur la société que l'on veut
construire fait ça me paraît quand même
un peu compliqué or aujourd'hui on voit
bien que la sur ce sujet là désolé de
dire monsieur le président je pense
qu'il n'y a pas consensus sur la société
que l'on veut construire ou alors ça se
saurait mais on peut peut-être quand
même aller vers ce que rappelait en
effet monsieur faire nous tout à l'heure
c'est à dire que hong haeran viennent à
des fondamentaux qui est que chacun
contribue en fonction de ses capacités à
faire en sorte que le pays est une
dynamique économique sociale qu'ils
puissent véritablement se construire moi
je crois que c'est ça quand même le
fonds qui devraient être présents dans
nos débats et moi j'avoue que le je
disais à mes collègues la page des échos
aujourd'hui sur la fiscalité du
patrimoine avec quelques quelques
remarques quand même qui montre comment
certains arrivent à ne plus payer alors
qu'il devrait quand même contribué mieux
je trouve qu'elle est intéressante
un peu plus d'oeuvres pédagogique pour
montrer comment certains échappent à
l'impôt alors qu'ils devraient
contribuer plus à la à l'intérêt général
me semble intéressant françois fortassin
dernier intervenant merci monsieur le
président moi je voudrais évoquer un
certain nombre de choses qui ont déjà
été dites mais y ajoute et peut-être
quelques points bien précis
d'abord effectivement partir de quelques
données très simple que vous avez évoqué
les uns et les autres que l'impôt doit
être payé en fonction des capacités
contributives de chacun qu'il y à une
contribuer
progressivité de l'impôt comme l'a dit
notre collègue on en profite ce à quoi
sert l'impôt et puis nos concitoyens ils
sont attachés à l'équité et après si on
me répond à ces questions on va
automatiquement gommer ce que j'appelle
les frilosités les peurs de ceux qui
partiraient à l'étranger mais de toute
façon ils partiront quand même parce
qu'on est on m'a quand même arrivé dans
ce pays à quelque chose absolument
extraordinaire ubuesque
c'est à dire qui arrivant qui peuvent
payer les impôts mais tu y trouve toutes
les combines pour le prépayé et d'autres
qui voudraient en payer qu'il en paye
pas parce que ils sont dans la misère la
plus totale
ça c'est c'est un élément fondamental
et puis est ce que le problème majeur
dans ce pays
c'est la crainte qu'un certain nombre de
riches quittent le pays
ou bien alors que notre pays aille dans
le mur parce qu'on a des déficits qui
sont abyssaux et qui se creuse de plus
en plus alors comment laurent ont fait
pour les réduire
on est pense - ça c'est une première
possibilité mais la deuxième c'est quand
même aussi d'essayer de renflouer les
caisses de l'état en faisant payer ce
qu'ils peuvent payer
moi je vous dirais que je suis satisfait
de payer impôts parce que je pense
effectivement à trop de gens qui
voudraient y aurait peut-être le bonheur
d'en payer et qui ne se poserait pas la
question de savoir si éventuellement on
peut pas trouver quelques niches
fiscales ici ou là
messieurs si vous faites bref ça n'est
pas un inconvénient
donc ce que vous voulez bien comment je
ne peux plus des commentaires qui ont
été fait finalement que que des
questions particulières m me lasse yeux
d'abord je réponds à serge dassault le
chiffre de 1000 personnes
c'est une extrapolation puisque les
chiffres de bercy sont de 300 à 500
personnes et geste rappelait à partir de
mes propres chiffres
et voilà comment je suis arrivé à 1000
premiers points deuxième point les gens
qui partent sont pas des gens qui en
patrimoine de 750000 euros
ce sont des gens qu un patrimoine
supérieur la tranche marginale et par
conséquent ce sont des gens qui ont un
patrimoine supérieur à 20 30 millions
d'euros est bien supérieur si on fait un
calcul simple en prenant simplement la
tranche marginale le taux marginal par
mille personnes et si on le multiplie
par le nombre d'années
il ya une accélération une année
lorsqu'on a mais la surtaxe monsieur
juppé avait bien sûr taxe était une très
bonne année délocalisations les gens
sont partis très nombreux à ce moment là
eh bien on arrive à des sommes
considérables et si on considère que ces
gens qui partent consommerez dépenserez
investir et c'est par plusieurs
milliards de paires de tva de droits de
succession et qu'on aurait beaucoup de
beaucoup d'argent
quant à la question tout à l'heure qui a
été posée remarque il faut pas rêver il
faut pas croire qu'il suffit d'augmenter
les impôts et que les riches sont
suffisants pour combler des déficits
d'abord parce que il ya mille 700 foyers
qui sont à la tranche marginale de l'
isf
si on est on leur prend 100 % ça
comblera pas le déficit
c'est pas possible et ils partiront donc
deuxièmement ce qui est des systèmes qui
permettent d'économiser l'impôt de façon
parfois ubuesque mais ça vient tout
simplement parce qu'on a mis en place
des taux trop élevés et qu'on a créé par
derrière
blain d'échappatoire pour éviter d'avoir
des impôts trop élevés donc il faut
revenir à la raison d impôt à assiette
large et à taux faibles et à ce moment
là on aura plus de montage qui font
vivre les professionnels dont je suis
quant aux niches qui rentrent dans la
même encadrent ça pose le problème de
l'impôt l'impôt à l'origine c'était pour
simplement donner de l'argent à l'état
pour faire fonctionner ses services
régaliens puis ensuite en a voulu que
l'impôt une fonction une fonction
sociale fonctions politiques une
fonction économique et à partir de là on
a créé des niches et on a créé des
niches on les a multipliées faut
peut-être revenir à des raisons est
peut-être arrivée une définition quelle
société on veut qu est ce qu on veut
quelle politique on veut privilégier et
diminuer tout ça mais je ne pense pas
monsieur le sénateur et que cet anodin
le fait des gens qui partent ce n'est
pas anodin c'est pas anodin anodin c'est
très grave
c'est très très grave parce que ça crée
un état d'esprit et qui dépasse le
montant de l'impôt etc
c'est ça c'est les jeunes qui partent
des familles qui partent et ces nations
qui se vident de sa substance
donc je crois que c'est une erreur sur
pas pour autant qu'il faut parquet
d'impôts c'est pas vrai il n'ya pas de
démocratie sans impôts il n'y a pas
d'état sans impôts donc il faut des
impôts et qui est nécessaire mais il
faut un moment on ne compte le
contribuable ne supporte plus l'impôt ça
devient l'enjeu
mais vous commencez à gauche et ali oui
juste effectivement à ce stade je pense
qu'il faut bien
faire la différence entre des problèmes
d'équité et les problèmes de financement
de déficit budgétaire
quand on parle de 40 50 60 milliards on
ne peut parler que de financement sur la
grande masse et de réduction de la
dépense aussi parce que on est quand
même arrivé à 55 56 % après la crise
je vois pas comment on peut continuer et
il n'est pas prouvé que les pays qui
sont bien en dessous et des qualités de
service plus faibles que les nôtres donc
après l épreuve d'équité les points
d'équité se posent sur les sujets qu'on
a dit là simplement sur le patrimoine
comme l'a dit et même en acier tout à
l'heure il ya trois façons de taxer le
patrimoine et à la détention annuel qui
est c'est vrai que l'on réfléchit
aujourd'hui il y a les plus values et il
y a les successions donations
chaque fois qu'on essayait de parler du
sujet de façon un peu général écran
principe quand on taxe l'impôt sur la
fortune dit c'est pas ça qu'il faut
faire il faut taxer les plus values
quand acheter plus alourdi s'est passé
quoi faire c'est autre chose on a eu le
rapport blue 20 tôles qui nous
expliquait qu'il fallait pas faire d'
impôt sur la fortune
après nous expliquer qu'au contraire il
fallait pas faire de droits de
succession au naf
pendant quelques années est était un des
rares pays qui taxer lourdement les
trois mais comme justement c'est
insupportable on a tellement multiplier
les avantages les niches les pactes des
trucs des machins qu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui il faut reconnaître que
contexte plus beaucoup sur aucun des
trois sur les en tout cas les
patrimoines les plus importants et les
revenus plus importants
là où on pourrait au moins espérer un
consensus si on veut que le contraire
les confiance c'est qu'on nous dise une
fois pour toutes
est-ce qu'on veut taxer la détention du
ls qu'on veut taxer la plus value est ce
qu on veut taxer la de la transmission
et comment après que dans les
alternances politiques on change
complètement les taux c'est normal mais
qu'on change pas d'avis tout le temps
parce que les gens vivent deux nations a
dit m
manque de chance il fallait pas l'
affaire ben oui bon et nous conseille on
est obligé quelques fois de jouer mais
vraiment à pile ou face pour conseiller
les gens pensent qu'on peut être
démentis du jour au lendemain
mon professeur
mais moi je dirais une tueuse pour
manière plus générale c'est vrai que
toutes les stratégies que qu'on
contribue à mettre en place un tous
autant que l'on ait font quoi mais y
avait il y avait quand même une étude
qui avait été faite par le le centre
d'étude des coûts des revenus et des
coûts le sert qu'à l'époque en 1996 sur
le cette question de l'imposition de la
population et la population avait été
divisé en décide
et pour déterminer quel était le taux de
prélèvements obligatoires que je
supportais le décile le plus bas est
celui qui portait tout l'étrange est
celui le plus haut et les gens qui
étaient ça m'avait frappé parce que les
gens qui étaient dans le décile le plus
élevé avec un taux de prélèvement de 40
8%
clémente auto obligatoire alors que la
personne du premier décide tout en bas
qui gagne rien elles paient plus de 43%
bon donc un problème de deux de ses
stratégies auxquelles il faut réfléchir
la façon dont offres doivent être
envisagés listes fiscales quelles sont
les conditions qu'il faut mettre qu'il
faut mettre à ça et puis enfin quand
même favoriser une fiscalité
je reviens ce que j'ai dit au début un
favoriser une fiscalité pour les
professionnels le professionnel c'est
celui qui crée qui créent de l'emploi
qui crée des revenus et et celui là doit
être moins imposés que les autres
l'argent dormant doit être taxé l'argent
dormant doit être taxé et c'est comme ça
que parce que steam ou taxi l'argent
dormant vous taxez qui les personnes les
plus fortunées donc qui n'est pas
d'accord avec ce principe
globalement oui mais je veux dire les
gens qui sont en bas si on met un taux
marginal de l'impôt sur revenu sur tous
les revenus ainsi twitté je vais dire on
va et rétablir un équilibre qui sera
acceptable par d'autres et je parle en
perspective d'avenir parce que ça peut
être acceptable par d'autres ceux qui
ont le ce genre de raisonnement
voilà ce que je voulais dire tout
simplement
mais est-ce qu'on prenne la mettre un
terme à cette présentation de l'impôt
qui consiste à dire qu'une partie de
l'impôt est payée par l'entreprise et
une autre partie par les ménages est-ce
qu'on ne pourrait pas reconnaître que
l'impôt est toujours payé par les
ménages et nous tirer pleinement les
conséquences
oui après comme dit michel taly un
problème des cotisations sociales machin
s'agite patronale très employé notamment
reconnus mais aucune différence
l'économie sont toujours les sont
toujours les ménages qui payent
malicieux sur donc l'économie était à
peu près temps c'est commode et
politiquement extrêmement corrects
patrons paient en fait sont les
consommateurs qui payent pas l'impôt qui
n'est pas répercutée dans le prix
demandé aux consommateurs
si on pouvait trouver un consensus sur
ce principe pourrait entamer une vraie
réforme fiscale couple bien messieurs
merci infiniment d'avoir éclairé la
commission des finances du sénat
un moment très très riche puisque vous
aviez experts sont fondés sur des
constatations objectives et donc vous
n'êtes pas dans la vision
virtuel des comportements fiscaux merci
nous aurons sûrement l'occasion de vous
inviter à nouveau pour parfaire notre
réflexion et peut-être pourrez-vous
constaté ce jour là que nous avons
progressé dans le sens une volonté
commune d'arriver à un peu comme on l'a
fait pour la loi organique sur la haute
finance un jour le parlement s'est dit
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour y voir
plus clair et mieux piloter la dépense
publique coûte l on n'aurait pas
vraiment appliqué le système
d'information est défaillant bon mais
voilà le jour où chorus opérationnelle
sera très bien et ministère de la
défense à deux programmes d'éducation
non mais ne suffit pas d'y voir clair
long de tous il suffit pas d'y voir
clair pour être courageux c'est la fin
de cette table ronde de la commission
des finances du sénat sur la réforme de
la fiscalité du patrimoine pour la
revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
merci de votre fidélité et à très
bientôt sur notre antenne